hey what's up my name's Samuel Leeds and
I'm gonna interview somebody who has
become financially free making seven and
a half thousand pounds a month and he's
done that by watching other people's
stories that I've interviewed on this
channel so hopefully by watching him
you'll be able to do the exact same
walking onto the show emanuelle take me
back then what made you in the first
place
sign up to the crash course I only have
got me into this I mean I was literally
on YouTube right just google it about
the research in how to make money online
extra cash and then I stumbled across
one of your videos on YouTube it was
actually the video where one of your
students had secured his first HMO when
you went with him to collect the keys
was in Middlesbrough okay for you when
you saw the house you did the figures
and I was thinking like who is this guy
and he's going to movie student to the
house picking up the keys out looked and
I literally just I remember I binge
watching you know and you watch those a
Netflix series is what a lot of support
leads videos on YouTube binge watched
all of them and how does what I needed
to know more I didn't found a book when
I was a yeah finally alright hi and like
I know I'm a reader anyways but I've
never read a book so fast before in my
life like I think the first chapters we
spoke about church yeah and how church
is view on your welfare your ability
through property and how that conflicted
I was like now this is nuts
you believe that related to that and I
literally read through your book within
like a day or so yeah and I was like I
needed morning it more and then you had
the back of the book you have
the crash course information about it
signed up to the very next one was at
the point I wasn't that point I didn't
care it was gonna be there
luckily it wasn't bothering them so I
went to the one who was in june/july is
that this year what's the last year last
year last year yeah so I went into the
crash course VIP out at the front seat I
literally hooked and then I remember you
called out and said if you want to be a
millionaire common stage now and I I ran
up on stage and funny enough when you
interviewed Jordan and yes they were
also on stage as one that's I know and
then you told us to kind of like to lead
everyone in their dance moves I don't
know remember that I don't you don't
sounds like the kind of thing that would
happen
yeah like it literally fool that was
yesterday like I'm Torri one else do the
middle rock hey teach but I just
remember I'm just leaving the crash
course was like rejuvenating I felt like
because up until that point I have
always wanted to be tragically free I
didn't know how yeah well after the
crash course I left thinking okay I've
got a plan yeah like it just became real
to me have you stayed in touch of anyone
filming for the course
yeah Jordan yes and then now also follow
chief or of course of course like we met
at the pin event in Coventry and we're
planning to meet up again in a couple of
weeks tarah yeah so talk me through what
happened there after after the program
so you've now watch the videos yeah
wrote the book you've attended the crash
course yeah
what what happened then okay so and when
I left the crash course I remember
thinking okay right there's so many
things to do here this you spoke about
how to secure single that deals and I
otherwise spoke about HMOs spoke about
the service combination you spoke out at
least option it's quite a lot in those
two days to take away and for the first
couple of months I was kind of just
confused I would say confused I didn't
know I wanted to do all of them and then
thankfully you're winners are the
Wednesday's keeps you kick started at
winners of the Wednesday yeah have you
started with the gentleman I had
so she was securing in one of the
trainings working but yeah yeah yeah
okay let me look at these options and I
was looking into it get as much
information as I could and then you
interviewed Leslie Cockney a softer out
then she went into detail about service
accommodation and I'm lucky I think I
like service accommodation so I started
to find books that I could find on it
and then you did a you and your brother
Russell you did a service accommodation
video on YouTube and I kind of just
nailed it home for me yeah and then the
icing on the cake was your interview
with Leah and her mom yeah I was like
yeah this is for me and so over that
that was about two month period of me
learning what's in your videos and you
putting out content just kind of helped
me to focus on one thing and then I
decided service accommodation room was
don't want it to go that's correct so
you kind of at the crash course yeah
hide your eyes opens I got the strategy
for financial freedom yeah got the
contacts the network yeah the passion
the understanding here and then you
continue to go back need to begin to
watch more videos watching percent and
really huge large it's all the free
stuff because it's great it's a lot of
information out there yeah so great for
free I don't know I know there's paid
programs that wiki where we help people
with the implementation yeah but I don't
believe either you pay a company at
everything you do all the free stuff
yeah you've read the books you attended
the seminars
you've watched all the YouTube videos
you've watched the interviews you've
connected your network
yeah what was your first deal it had
about them so my first deal was just
before Christmas in Manchester so up
until that point I think Cheryl
mentioned a book called golfin oh yes
which for me changed my life like
there's a few books so the Bible Rich
Dad Poor Dad and then go for know yeah
up until that point I was getting a lot
of rejection in terms of trying to
secure a lease option try to secure HM
or when I narrowed it down to focus on
essay and started ringing up agents
bringing up landlords and on gumtree
spare room so those are know that I kind
of just took
a relaxed view on it but when she said
go for knowing I read that book and I
realized that failure is actually a part
of the process yeah that changed the
game for me like it just changed my
mindset was up before that I always
thought once you fail it's over you know
especially in the Nigerian culture if
you're failure you get labeled a failure
and you know parents tell parents and
rumors start going around but that book
changed my whole concept of failure it
was no longer that you know the more you
fail the further away from success you
are it was more the more you fail the
closer you get to success so literally
from October I was hammering the font
you know rejection rejection rejection
but I knew not getting closer
Jim I very first yes and then first the
December came and I got my first yes so
I couldn't quite believe it at the time
by the father okay keep my cool don't
get too excited it's not over the line
yet then your schedule of viewing to
Manchester went to Manchester had a look
at the property and told them what I
wanted to do with it the landlord was a
portfolio a landlord so he didn't
necessarily care too much he just wanted
some security in his income and security
in the maintenance of the property which
is all of the things I was promising
Bhuvan provided yeah and then the deal
was done so we secured it for three
years and deal with a 12-month pretty
close
that's fantastic go for know you said it
was a real pivotal changer and that was
mentioned by many owners on the loose
that I know I know that's one of the
books that we beat on the Academy as
well right so it's it's it's great you
read that what does it mean go for that
so what it means it's all on the book is
services yes there's a destination no is
the journey yeah so going for know is
pretty much me and you when you get um
no you don't take it as the end you know
in fact you should actually go for it so
what I did right so I would have a
target I want to get 20
knows in a week yeah so literally even
if I got a yes
it didn't matter my goal wasn't to go
for yes my goal was to secure 20 nose
and before I knew it like specially
after on my first deal it's like anymore
yes sister knows and it's that become a
problem to get nose so that's that's the
ever know it's a brilliant philosophy
because you haven't actually failed
because if you get twenty nose and you
don't get it yes yes you can celebrate
the nose there's no exam and it's
focusing on the activity rather than the
result but we know that the result will
come when we do the activity yeah that's
a complete mind like shift yeah you know
to celebrate
rejection celebrate knows but it's so
effective and then you've got your first
year since December yes sir so how much
money did you have two points that deal
so on the very first deal was quite
fortunate because the property self just
Brandon you've been refurbished yeah so
literally I had to put about two and a
half per end in terms of brand-new
furniture and then I've got a painter to
come and painting some features because
I really wanted it to kind of stand out
above the competition yeah so we have to
because especially Manchester City
Centre
yeah there were so many listings or
their being me okay calm so I'm gonna
just kind of stand out and I realized
like feature world helped it to stand
out and so overall the first deal a
deposit down but the ring itself was
nine hundred yeah the deposit was about
thirteen hundred I had to then pay fees
at that time they still was
fees you have to pay because things
change now and you yeah well yeah so
overall about five thousand pounds yeah
willing okay my first deal and you and
that Monet that five thousand was that
from savings if you borrow the money
what I was from savings see because up
until that point I'd worked and seemed
to put a lot and before the crash course
other than the process of actually
buying a first bite of that property but
then when I got to the crash course to
learn about what he strategies that kind
of held off yeah actually tell her like
I was so I really played solicitor fees
and everything but I decided to kind of
cancelled
transaction and I lost all the money for
the fees but I didn't care because I
realized that is a problem put fake
right in one house and we stuck with one
house if I can know this I can walk five
grand in one property and then before
you know I have six properties we got
30k back control mmm it just made more
sense to do that way chest here so I
lost about two thousand pounds in terms
of cancelling the transaction yeah I
don't regret you go to the big picture
of this one a big picture because it
just made sense to me why would after
thirty thousand in one house and just be
stuck and then you know same up say what
say what say what say what weekend and
then get another house when I couldn't
have 30 grand I could control six
properties well I did it take you coming
to the crash course to figure that out I
had no idea open to that point because
my mom has one property so and if she's
had that for years now you know she's
been trying to say what to get another
one so that was the knowledge I had up
until that point yeah get one property
and just same work work safe and get
another one takes a long time to become
financially free doing it the
traditional one hundred percent because
you know my mom still is not financially
free and one day you financially for it
I'm financially free but I'm still
working towards getting my mom
financially free that's great yes really
really good yeah so the first day people
five growing it you sort of had in that
moment I found out really well so
thankfully we caught the Christmas
market so by the end of so we were alive
for like 14 days in December and then we
made over a thousand pounds profit so
after I paid management fees and paid
the bills paid the rent at least in the
property still to a 1000 pound I was
like this was half the month hi Arjun
bear in mind it was a Christmas period
as well so we did charge more or maybe
half period but we didn't walk away with
thousand pounds that's incredible
okay so what about what about the
following month and up until now what's
the sort up until that point there's
pretty much been that deal every month a
deal so a new property every single
month so you've got a total of five
deals no I've got a total now of nine
nine that's more that's more than it no
it's not we're a long time while still
so yeah what's up average about one
point two properties a month what an
example of consistency so that first
deal you got in Manchester you made a
thousand pounds in half a month you have
for how much you making just on that one
deal on average each month on that one
deal or making more than 1,600 pounds
internal clear profit every month every
month good deal it's Massey Center
whenever there's home games free night
or Manchester City yeah the hotels trip
on a price
yeah which would bring our prices as
well the thing is though 1600 pounds on
one day or one deal and you for five
grand in that for some people it's
financial freedom for some people that
would replace an income yeah I have to
be honest when I got my second deal back
in January I've pretty much financially
free back then how would she make you
now that in total but you know so let's
go off the last month
so I'm tall so we made just over 15 and
a half thousand pounds for the month of
July I see after though all expenses we
walked away with over seven and a half
thousand seven one thousand pound profit
that's my profit so after all of these
bills everything rules we have seminar
and that's a pretty standard month now
for you that's done in Libya that's
incredible it's nuts it's faded now you
must you must be pretty impressed with
yourself it hasn't sunk in yet
yeah it still feels like okay alright
that's that's not about goals
my goal is secure 20 deals Jerry
properties but in the year yes so I've
not kind of giving my
myself a chance to celebrate yet I'm
just recycling the money to celebrate if
you guys should say I don't know how to
celebrate their Lobby here is a
celebration true
I made one year ago to this date is when
you were watching live Cheryl yeah
Leslie yeah yeah thinking fingers
crossed one day one day did you know
that you were gonna be successful yes
tell me about that from I must speak to
my mom couple weeks ago and you know she
I've told her about my journey and she
brought me back to when I was in a
secondary school in year 8 so why do I
say before my dinner money for a week
and we would go to foreign foods was not
big no but you know our backpacks of my
wines start busts and banana bags
so over the weekend I kind of like put
it all together little bags of like 20
30 back when I walk to school and I will
be selling those banks to each student's
yeah and you know we started to get some
cash aside to recruit people that is
below and so that lasted for about two
months and then I got shut down my head
teacher found out it's really useful
it's probably don't courage that might
think they don't encourage leadership
and they should but they won't why is
that because Robert Kiyosaki said that
the best you know they want to keep
April poor yeah yeah it does the reality
of it you know yeah because I mean a lot
a lot of people that are very successful
in business when you look back at their
history you know they used to do stuff
like that
yeah you know I was I used to do stuff
like that so magic trick yeah yeah by
things and sell them more expensive to
school kids I think it's in our DNA
yeah I honestly believe that do you
think that our training keep in
throughout training do you think that
that can work for anyone or do you think
you have to be in a very special kind of
person I think you can work for anyone
however you have to be committed to it
mmm you know it's you can have the
blueprint it's like I can take you to
you I can show you a blueprint
take you show you the journey show you
the map is there gonna get there but
also maybe you have to get off your butt
and do what's necessary yeah how does
your work I think it's because the way
you've had all the information like you
said it's accessible you just need to go
out and make the calls make connections
yeah just put the work in
yeah and I think anyone can do it like
it's pretty simple
hey anyone can't but not anyone well
maybe well yeah
what's your strongest reason why then my
strongest reason why was my son yeah my
son is that to Israel and I don't want
him to grow up needing anything you know
I don't want to spoil him but I also may
only be in a position where I can spend
time with him I can be give him the best
education the best life the best house
and just set him up you know and even my
wife was well she's another reason why
you know just wanting to you could your
upbringing plays a part
yeah you know and you know it we didn't
live rich you know but my mom worked her
butt off yeah she worked her socks off
and seeing that I wanted to just not
work like that for the rest of my life
yeah and I just wanted that freedom so
Israel's - he's got a real life in
Northampton it's a property salad what's
next what's next so my goal is to hit my
target 2020 Benjamin's 20-year editor
yes and you know the good news she can
become a billionaire in many ways I know
I know but my goal is was about 20 I
want to then use that to fund wedding
venues okay olive oil into the wedding
venue industry because I do have a but I
have off wedding photography business as
well now and I kind of
I've got very user thank you she's some
people might be thinking that look
Emmanuelle you might be several golf
grandma
yeah we've no enhancers you know not
properties you want to get to twenty you
gonna be making like fifteen twenty one
a month fear why themself I know that
business why not just relax bear home
like I can't it's just for me what makes
me happy is all that work between the
happiest is when this progression yeah I
can't if I'm keeping still I'm not happy
even though it financially we weren't
good the fact that we're not doing
anything will make me the first you know
I always got to keep on progressing is
your other growth that you're addicted
to the broth that's what so in terms of
celebrating success which we mentioned
earlier for me one of the best feelings
when I get a key you know the key
dangling yeah yeah that for me is like
the most accomplishing feeling and
that's how I spied you because you know
you've gotten any of our advanced
training so I don't see where the
dinners and there's you know the
training programs but I do see you on
the Facebook group yeah dangling keys
you usually every three or four weeks
yeah there's a video or a picture of you
with some new keys yeah and after seeing
that I get it again in the game I know
my team we reached out to you intercept
though you've got to come on the show
what would you say the biggest the
biggest takeaway that you've got from
both your training but also your
experience like what's the if you had to
leave watches or if you were advising
yourself from a year or two ago I was
the biggest lesson that you've learned
all of this I think for me is getting
the education getting a mentor because
for me it took me what six months before
I got my first deal which I feel like if
I had
mentorship and then time we would have
been quick on yeah yeah you doing all
the free stuff yeah it's really
interesting when I started out Oh
I mean I'm messing myself alone but I
also held back at times yeah and then
sometimes by the time I was like you
know I I can afford it now and then I
did the program I thought damn I wish
I'd done it
are you able to go yeah like do you want
do you do you regret not doing more
drugs that you would've got that quicker
I wouldn't blow that quicker I do regret
but also the experiences I went through
yeah what necessary experience is the
best teacher experience is the best
teacher but then if you can experience
then you're smart yeah yeah and yeah
yeah we completely agree with that
sample I mean it I don't know why at the
time I guess I'll just kind of maybe
being greedy is it work but I feel like
if I was to go back anyways yeah and I
knew I have to catch all of them that
yeah because you could do it now but if
you do it now you'd have already learned
a lot of stuff yourself yes yeah but
still yeah yeah seven half grand profit
month is absolutely incredible what has
been the hardest thing that you go
through all the other biggest mistake
biggest challenge over the last year I
think for me the hardest thing was just
the changing of my mind
you know changing on my mind towards
failure that was a hard thing to kind I
mean that um at the time I was 27
so I've gone through my whole life 27
years thinking failure was a bad thing
yeah but then after we go for know after
all you're winners on a Wednesday to
your success students to be able to
change your mind about a concept that's
you've grown up with mmm with so it was
really hard yeah really and out of my
house challenge as soon as I overcame
that door started opening yeah amazing
and you know what's really cool is you
inspire all those winners Wednesday
stories and and probably if it wasn't
for those stories put it wouldn't be
here but now getting back that you're
here yeah sank my living room it's crazy
yeah
so I predict that there's gonna be
people who watch this hopefully better
inspired like you inspired for the end
of samurai that hundred percent so
honestly if it wasn't for winners on a
Wednesday combined with a crash course I
definitely would not be here I guess it
up so it's all dude I'm so impressed
you've caught my attention thank you
sighs I look forward so you've got a
good like you're good man another thing
you got to do more things
thank you
[Music]
[Music]